how's it going good how are you good I
feel like like you're gonna know what to
expect because we were just we were
urinating next to each other and we were
like yes right we were reflecting on the
inappropriate things we had said to her
twice man-to-man comparing so you know
it's cool so everything's okay well
welcome Tim Mathis thank you thank you
it's great to be here we saw you and I
knew we were from the side I need you're
playing Reagan and you definitely I'm
not even you do resemble somebody that's
absolutely our next guy yeah you know
it's it's interesting because I've been
I played Reagan once before you know
with Jay Thomas actually in a pilot that
he had done Jay Thomas the radio guy
yeah okay also also a formidable actor
yellow and he's paying me to say that
and but I was also approached to do a
one-man show with as Reagan but the show
is i but it was uh I will said Nancy and
I just said that wouldn't be funny okay
it's hard to play some he's he's
somebody people do a lot of people do
impressions of it's uh it's kind of hard
how do you get his how do you get him
without seem like you're doing an
impression of well that was the trick it
was the big trap I think was the sound
to be doing a bad impression of Reagan
so or I figured my nightmare was to
sound like Johnny doing Reagan Johnny
Carson right you know because it's so on
YouTube and it that was my biggest fear
so I just I just I work from the inside
out so I just wanted to get enough of a
sound like Reagan so the people would
say yeah yeah that's him
yeah and and the look is there so you
know that's what I was when you look at
Frank Langella I think who did who
nicked it and in the frost/nixon
yes he didn't do a bad Nixon impression
he sound like but you could see that he
was just playing kind of the guy and it
worked
yeah yeah he wasn't trying to do that
like get the voice impression yeah I
didn't yes it in college but I stopped
doing it you did an impression of Reagan
I mean [ __ ] the black hooker behind a
book
the beauty was a much smarter guy than
people why only one who wants to master
Community College I gotta be in three
EPs I would never have guessed
me neither no maybe you're our second
actually we were talking about this your
second Regan we've had in today we have
Bruce Campbell in before you and Bruce
played Ronald Reagan on Fargo Oh on the
TV series like for one episode yeah yeah
yeah oh that's too funny
yeah I gotta check that out yo Colin
Quinn does an amazing Reagan you know
Colin Quinn yeah he does probably the
best Reagan but all he does and he
doesn't do it much in his act but he's
done it on the radio and it's a perfect
Ronald Reagan yeah yeah it's it it's
it's it's interesting there's Frank
Langella right there right yeah yeah it
was a good Nixon have you seen Nixon
Elvis and Nixon yes it's great to see
that but I thought Michael Shannon was
an interesting choice to play Elvis and
young Spacey
not a lot like Elvis though you know the
fav my favorite scene in it is is when
the Elvis impersonator comes up to him
to Elvis and yell in the airport yeah
and and says you know you're not a very
good Elvis but I did let me show you
know and doesn't know was him personally
think this is better than Michael
Shannon well yeah I wonder why they got
him that was Justin really he said he
doesn't look like Elvis a lot he was too
thin because he was thin and Elvis at
that point was just drugged out of his
mind and and there wasn't any of that so
it was I think the script had give him
some limitations but that's just Mike
yeah yeah
so speaking of scripts like killing
Reagan is a Bill O'Reilly book yeah and
I know this because he's plugged it at
the end of his show like the last 15
minutes of his show is is uh it's just
plugging whatever's on his website but
um was he at all involved in the movie
in the making of no he came in at the
end he came down to the visit to set one
day very tall
yeah you've met bill so I mean easy and
he's huge he's like six five six
something like that but very bright guy
and it was very apolitical didn't we
didn't discuss politics so there none of
that came up and I just found him I
found him very smart and it was an
astute thing this this series of books
would be a career for the normal person
yeah listen to what he does at Fox so
it's really smart this drama the this
you know the the killing of series that
he's done is great and with Regan it's
interesting because he's not killed
right by my ass and so it's this story
goes on after he's been shot so I it's
it's a it's a little different than all
the other so it's about Hinckley and
leading up to exactly okay yeah he did
O'Reilly done a series of write books he
did killing Kennedy and katydid killing
Jesus he's done all of them and he and
you're right it would be a career and
he's smart to then turn them around and
turn them into movies and and there's
like you know five more of these there
that are coming and I think they're
they're I forget what's going next but
gently Michael Jackson it's the do you
worry at all because I mean it's a good
thing because he's gonna promote the
[ __ ] out of the movie on his show
garbage can I shouldn't
it's huge promotional tool but you're
not a political you're pretty I'd like
on Twitter you're pretty clear about
your opinions in the your Hillary
Clinton supporter and very very against
Donald Trump are you worried that like
people on the o'reilly side of things
are gonna find out about you through the
movie or you know it's a oh let me check
him out on twitter and then be like you
know when I do a right I'm gonna do a
Reilly tonight and Fox and Friends
tomorrow I'm just I'm chicken [ __ ] I'm
not gonna say anything I'm just gonna go
no no no vote vote vote right I'm not
gonna tell you who to vote for but when
I go there I'll just be a political but
you know because on Twitter you're not
even sort of April and it's no very very
clear well that's the best part though
is that you get all these O'Reilly fans
to come in there and then they they see
that you're a big Hillary supporter and
a neo and I played your favorites on you
[ __ ]
so upset yeah Twitter you know yeah I
used to like you [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
you how could you submit Benghazi you
know I mean that's not what I meant but
I go nuts yeah yeah like yeah and it's
people like I've grown up watching you
Obama and you betrayed me yeah like you
could still watch the movie it's just
politics in the movie itself is not
about the politics yeah because right as
I said you can't act the politics you
can only act the person and and the the
inner spirit of that and you know and
really what it's it's the killing Reagan
is basically a story about John Hinckley
and about the Reagan's and it's a love
story about Ronnie and Nancy it really
is what that side of the story is in the
White House so it's that's really what
it is not his politics that much so you
bet your basic thing is just get out
there involved yeah I like that you just
okay because I I started the campaign
years ago as nobody people were scared
to get on board with years ago it was a
vote if you're not busy I mean you know
P Diddy can't vote or die you rogue vote
if you're not busy
yeah guys a little dramatic what if
you're stuck in traffic you gotta hang
yourself no we'll find you so angry just
got out true that's kind of yeah do you
think that a guy like that who actually
I think once you shoot a president for
any I don't care what your mental health
is you should never get out of jail I'm
with you you know I'm kind of it's like
okay you were guilt guilty by reason of
insanity by reason of insanity but when
are you saying you know this guy has a
conventicle condition that is ongoing
and but I evidently they did determine
that he's harmless you know yeah right I
don't know yeah I mean even if it's like
even if he is harmless punish him anyway
what are you shot Reagan you did it do
you like doing political like acting
sure maybe not you Jim because there's
this of course you know every knows you
from the West Wing and you've done some
other stuff do you like kind of going
into that world because the political
world is just incredibly it's insane
right insane
entertaining and I find that you know
the I love doing it I love doing
political drama and I for Americans I
think what's and there's a great you
know deal of interest in it because
obviously the politics of the world
right now and in that you know the
election but it's it's sort of America's
version of the histories of Shakespeare
you know it's sort of our king and queen
it's our royal family so that's really I
think what's interesting about it and
and that's why people are so drawn to it
yeah yeah and and I especially now
because now you've like included
showbusiness into it too like now it's
like well now the comedy should be you
remember the comedy dick did you ever
see differences in one show yeah yeah no
no I remember the movie dick yeah but
it's you know so I think that's there's
a tremendous capacity for that kind of
an appetite for that kind of drama do
you try to go back into like comedy with
a certain sort of regularity or do you
just as it comes out as well as it comes
out I love comedy yeah you know it's
it's it's the hardest thing to do but
it's the hardest thing to find because
it's it's the most difficult script to
write right you know as you know and
especially to like you do Animal House
and at such a young age is it to then
start looking at other comedy scripts
does it become like well but this isn't
that yeah a lot of that totally totally
I mean because there were so many things
they all they'll be like that and you
know it's like it's not I mean we've
done the movie 1941 which is Spielberg
Bob Zemeckis film you know which was
pretty good very underrated it's
underrated but very underrated but it
would there was a lot of the characters
did the same kind of humor in an animal
house I did a verbal kind of romantic
comedy and you know Belushi didn't
hardly have any done it was physical
comedy and
everybody had a different kind of comedy
that they did every character so it was
a unique script and it was it was a way
ahead of its time
but I'll tell you what I love it I think
we might even talked about this before
in the bathroom I think you said
something I want Frank McRae in is the
funniest guy on earth and and and he was
in used cars which i think is his Emeka
sensual Jack Wharton comedy which have
yapping about for year and in [ __ ]
hey get the back of the tank in 1941 and
even 48 hours he's one of the most
another underrated guy in Hollywood Cray
was a funny [ __ ] me I wish she
did more films he's alive though someone
come he's alive I think so we stopped
doing well I just sounded like you were
like saying that miraculously like he
was sick but he was so good yeah well
that's the bill o'reilly much book
killing Frank McRae but no the fact is
he's done so many fine things he's such
a funny guy
I always said you don't see him anymore
and said what happened to him well you
know it's it's that crazy thing about
show business it's like all of a sudden
nobody calls you you know I mean it's
like they're on you have good times been
you know that bad time you don't know
what you know like I'm out of the
business nobody let you know yeah it's
just how long how long have a string of
you gone on not realizing you know like
what's happening for more from 1990 till
now I hustle I you know I started
directing and producing so I'm always
doing something and it cuz you'll create
a project for yourself there isn't one
it was is the only way I kept my sanity
because you know and and that way I
could be unemployed in two different
jobs acting and it was it was the it was
the best sort of fallback thing for me
so I just didn't lose my mind and sit by
the phone line when's it gonna ring you
know that was so that's what I've
approached it and West Wing just got
eight lists because I never make lists
but the Rolling Stone top 100 shows I
said look at it I think West Wing was
right ahead of mash I want to see was 17
or 16 that's right
was 15 or 16 yeah yeah that's a
tremendously respected show ya how
losses Martin Sheen
oh he's fab I was very a stupid question
how awesome is Martin Sheen I know I
admit it was a terrible question at a
non point right I just happen to like
Martin Sheen here see Apocalypse Now God
that's trying to solve it do you watch
movies and not you know the questions
are gonna be directed to you we're doing
this be that way
do you watch movies and think like like
oh that was mine like that role with
like oh I could have nailed that no I'm
a great audience I just go I just go
into the film and I look at it more from
a director's point of view I think that
an act but I mean I could appreciate the
a sure thing and and and I'll definitely
get inspired by films that I've seen you
know and I saw Hamilton last night with
the play yeah is the original guy did he
leave Helen Manuel Oh - oh no the second
I think that's right yeah yeah you got
his ponytail off done how was it zero
interest in it and yet everybody raves
about it some like it's gotta be good I
just didn't know this was a it was so
different than what I expected there's
no guy there's no dialogue it's all
songs see that in me it works great
because it saw so many different kinds
of music and song and rap it's not a
wrap yeah Thomas did you seen it no but
I really want to any clip I see that I'm
like this it's astonishing it just
stands out on his head it's great the
direction and choreography and and it
just and history I'm very worried though
when I look at it because I don't I
don't I haven't seen it I don't want to
see it because I'm worried that it's
like you know like when you have the
teacher that thinks he's the cool
teacher and he starts rapping and he
thinks that like he can relate to the
kids and stuff like I'm not learning I
love that I wanted to be a teacher and
Michelle Pfeiffer in Dangerous Mind
inspired me to want to be a teacher yeah
which is given paydays yeah
yeah she's giving out like candy bars to
like the most dangerous kids that have
ever been like oh this is what we need
that's absolutely exactly and turned him
around didn't it yeah yeah you put that
gun away have a mars bar right inner
city youth but it wasn't it wasn't
Hamilton wasn't like that no it's it's
it's revolutionary it's excuse the pun
and it's it's fantastic and the music is
wonderful
you know what play I like lame is yes
yes wait I'm thinking of lacasa fall I
was in something in sexuality I got it
wrong once again only your mind did got
in there for some what play can I think
of no you're right sorry just thinking
what I was talking about yes I didn't
likely miss for that reason that I did
enjoy the Book of Mormon so it was one
of the great yes a masterpiece but I
just never liked singing the dialogue
it's I use it but I mean I just
discussed it yeah yes true yeah what was
uh what was everybody's got Chevy Chase
stores now and I feel like especially
after that show community he came out of
it looking very bad like everybody had
stories about him being like an [ __ ]
and all this stuff what was he like to
work with as a as a young man well Chevy
on Fletch Lynn was where I worked with
him yeah um it was but he was clean he
would just just sobered up and he was on
his best behavior so he was great but
you know inch but he patently admitted
he said I'm not an actor so you can you
try and break me up try throat you know
improvise throat lines at made insult me
so I would but you know when I when we
were doing his close-up
I would just riff on him and try and
break him up try and just shake him up
in some house because he wanted he knew
that he wanted a real reaction
because he didn't want to he couldn't
act it and just but he would get cuz he
was very very riffing you know and it
was so it was fun to work with and he
had a great director Michael Richie and
so it was it was great fun but I think
you know drugs were his problem and I
think that's what led him down you know
a bad bad path oh right right right
well they're saying you have to go but
killing Reagan premiers a Sunday October
16th at 8 o'clock and you're gonna be on
The O'Reilly Factor it's not National
Geographic by the way oh yeah I should
probably say them yeah give you a bad
plug I apologize so I basically just
said it's on go find it mother October
16th just scroll through the die exactly
just our heads on the 10 HD good luck to
you and Tim underscore Matheson is Tim
on Twitter if you want to follow him you
don't like understand we've setup what
he does on Twitter so don't just follow
him just to be like your another song
like you know if you don't want to read
something that you don't agree with and
you don't have to ask you to ringing I
never like to put people on the spot
I don't do oppressions though I mean
it's like it's not which menuju min the
movie well I what I did was I did you
know I did us it's I sounded like him
and I worked with you know cuz he hadn't
lowered his voice and you know there you
go again you know I mean it was just
what's that play the guy the old actor
thing is you play they say you play the
man not the uniform right because it's I
would have just done a bad impression
you know and I it's not my thing so but
so I just did it for the from the inside
out I think it's easier to get into a
character like that like I'm watching
you I really have to wrap up but we
talked about finally like if I'm not
watching a guy do an impression then you
just you just give ok that's what this
guy is it's him and then you just watch
it
and you try to remember I was it primary
colors the Bill Clinton movie which
revolta you wanted that role right yeah
I mean Pete Mike Clinton is really good
but I don't do them that much and it
look like him that's the problem
what does it sound
that was like you ever have to do a
killing Clinton we know where to come